the show starts on a secluded korean
island knock doo is a fisherman living
with his father and older brother he
learns martial arts from the village
drunkard master and is promised to marry
his daughter when he grows up one
afternoon knock dew and the girl are
fishing when a man informs him that his
family is in trouble he rushes back home
to see a group of soldiers surrounding
his father yoon and brother huang a
battle follows and nakdu manages to
defeat them all having learned martial
arts his entire life one of the soldiers
is a woman who knock dew refuses to kill
he hurts her leg and allows her to flee
when everything calms down nakdu's
father tells him they have to leave the
island now that they have been found
from a very young age he was overly
protective of his sons as if someone was
looking for them he claims that he did
something in the past which affected
many vengeful high profiles hence he
faked his death and was on the run for
decades but today's attack means that
someone has found their whereabouts the
drunkard master reveals that the
soldiers were trained assassins which
means they were sent by someone to kill
the family he wants nakdu to go to the
emperor's city and find out who is the
person behind the attack yoon doesn't
want his son to get into trouble but
nakdu has decided to get to the bottom
of the situation no matter what in the
next scene we are taken to the emperor's
city the king is making a round of the
city in a palanquin surrounded by his
guards a woman named dongju is dressed
up as a man and is looking to kill the
king to avenge something that happened
to her family she gets ready with her
bow and arrow but is interrupted by a
running knock do they bicker for a
minute which causes her to miss the
palanquin suddenly an old man throws a
stone at the king slandering him for
killing his son to expand his palace the
guards are instantly altered and asked
to check the entire area for the old
man's accomplice in the following brawl
both knock do and dongju are caught
right before he is taken away nakdu sees
the woman who he injured back on his
island he wants to use her to get to her
boss but the guards arrest him before he
can assuming that dongju is a man she is
kept with the male prisoners where she
meets knock do again they bicker and
blame each other for their situation the
following morning they wake up close to
each other and jolt up in embarrassment
the guards take them to the
investigation bureau and dongju is asked
to introduce herself she goes blank
knowing that any lie will get her in
trouble since she is disguised as a man
when the investigation officer gets mad
at her for not speaking nak do comes to
her aid and distracts everyone he claims
that the investigation is fruitless and
the king must instead go to the grave of
the old man's son to gain sympathy from
his people his suggestion is taken into
consideration and they are ultimately
let free after that noctu and dongju go
their separate ways nakdu ends up at a
local inn at night the kind in owner
offers him food free of charge out of
the goodness of her heart what noctu
doesn't know is that it has been
poisoned by the female assassin an hour
after eating the food he feels nauseous
and runs outside the inn owner runs to
call the assassin but by then nakdu has
already fled the woman assumes he is
dead and returns home to meet her boss
nakdu follows her having thrown the food
instead of eating it he sees her
entering a hidden village and goes in
after her however nakdu soon regrets the
decision because the village belongs to
widowed women and men are strictly
prohibited to enter the female guards
beat him up before throwing him out
later that day nakdu sees a woman being
chased by a group of men he helps her
escape and finds out she is being
pursued by her family for falling in
love with a man of a lower castle the
lovers want to escape but the men who
want her dead are still outside the
widow's village waiting for her to
arrive to help them nakdu dresses up as
a woman and tricks the men they
eventually assume that their daughter
has left and quit pursuing her noc do
acts so well as a woman that even the
couple is shocked they thank him greatly
before leaving for a safer village the
next morning nakdu goes to the widow's
village dressed as a woman they welcome
him after he makes up a story about his
husband's death there are two parts of
the village the common grounds and the
kasang house where unmarried women stay
since there are no rooms vacant in the
village nakhdu is asked to share a room
in the casang house the women there
survive by making alcohol and clothes
for the palace they promise to teach
nakhdu a skill and help him sustain a
good life as he is being shown around a
nobleman tries to kidnap a little girl
to make her his wife a woman stands
against him refusing to let the child be
exploited nakdu looks closer at the girl
and realizes it is dongju he sees that
she is a woman and figures out that she
was dressed as a man when they first met
to make the nobleman go away dongju cuts
her hair which is said to be a kasang's
sacred jewel when he still remains
adamant the king's nephew and dongju's
friend nyung yang comes to her rescue he
embarrasses the man and kicks him out of
the village as the crowd disperses nak
do meets the manager of the kasang house
mr lee he instantly falls for his beauty
nak do is sent to the room that he is
supposed to share with dongju he goes
through her belongings and makes sure
she is the person he met in the village
yesterday she finds him snooping through
her bag and pushes him away they get
into a fight again before dongju asks
him to stay away from her belongings and
kicks him out later the manager meets
knock do and takes him by surprise by
expressing his love noctu doesn't know
what to make of the unwanted attention
and resorts to staying away from the man
while looking for the assassin he
figures out that the village's brewery
is where most women aren't allowed to go
before he checks what's inside three
women forcefully make him come to the
river to bathe with them knock dude
doesn't want to seem suspicious nor does
he want to pass on this sweet
opportunity but if he takes off his
clothes his secret will be out he
refuses as much as he can before jumping
into the water with his clothes on
suddenly the women look at him in shock
and throw a stone in his direction nakdu
freezes in shock before realizing that
they are looking at a man behind him the
kasang manager is caught red-handed
spying on them they knock him out
deciding to never talk about this again
in the following scene we are introduced
to the king's most beloved friend and
subject hyo yoon long ago nokdu's father
used to be good friends with the king
and yoon but at the end of the war yoon
asked noctu's father to run away with
knock do so they wouldn't have to get
killed by his hands the reason he wanted
to kill them all is still a mystery but
it is clear that nokdu's father has been
running away from the king all this time
another flashback shows us that a few
months earlier noctia's father bumped
into a man who recognized him he managed
to escape then but the king was informed
and the soldiers were sent to look for
him around the islands back in the
present the king asks a commander if he
was able to find knock do but the man
lies and claims that they didn't find
anyone somewhere else eunice told about
nakdu coming to the city in search of
the woman who attacked him he tightens
the security around the widow village
hoping to catch nakdu before he is found
by the king meanwhile in the village
nakthu and dongju have a sleep together
in a room dongju doesn't mind it
assuming that nakdu is a woman but nak
do is nervous the entire time when
everyone is asleep at night he goes out
and finds a group of women dressed as
the assassins he fought on the island it
is revealed that their group kills
misogynists and predators who harm other
women however their leader is someone
only the older women recognize to get to
the leader noctu follows the said women
but he is caught after a fierce sword
fight he manages to run back to the
casang house and pretends to be taking a
stroll the following day nakdu goes into
the brewery to try to socialize but he
ends up getting into a fistfight with a
woman after unintentionally calling her
ugly amidst the fight noctu sits on a
hot pan and burns his back while dongju
burns her hand they help each other by
applying medicine before going to sleep
that night the king comes to meet yoon
and inquires if he saw nakdu and his
father dying with his own eyes uniforms
even though he knows that he let them
run away out of mercy the king has his
suspicions regarding the story but he
decides to let it go for the night after
he falls asleep yoon asks his best man
to continue looking for knock do the
next morning nakdu bumps into the
assassin who he fought on the island she
finds him familiar and follows him but
nakdu manages to fool her by pretending
to be the kasang manager's escort still
he has to be careful because the
assassin is keeping a close eye on him
for the rest of the day nakdu helps
dongju with different things because of
her injury they eventually become
friends and dongju even suggests that
she call him sister get wrecked nakdu on
the other hand refuses to be called that
and asks her to stick to calling each
other by their names when it turns dark
an eerie noise is heard prompting all
the women to run into their houses nakdu
is told that the elders are performing a
ritual for the dead widows and no one
should be out of their houses at this
time he sees through the ruse because
the women performing the ritual are the
elder assassins he follows them and sees
a group of men entering a temple where
men are forbidden they are the leaders
who run the entire widow assassin
organization before nakhdu can get a
look at their faces he trips alerting
the soldiers to his presence he runs
back to the kasang house and enters a
random room to his surprise dongju turns
out to be in the same room back at the
temple we see that yoon and his council
are the leaders of the organization the
king is looking to kill a kid who is the
only person in the line of the throne
after him yoon and his council are
secretly planning to dethrone the king
because he has gone insane for the
throne but they have to be extremely
careful about not letting any outsiders
know back in the kissang house nakdu
pretends to cut dongju's hair when the
assassins come looking for the intruder
but then she feels his chin and finds
stubble that proves he is a man nakdu
blackmails her since he knows about her
crossdressing to go to the city to his
luck this keeps her from outing him to
the assassins after everything calms
down nakdu lies that he ran away with
his mistress but they were separated by
her family the couple has many people
looking to kill them for simply falling
in love hence he is hiding in the
village until his lover arrives looking
for him dongju believes the story but
keeps a close eye on him to ensure he's
not a pervert in the morning the women
are provided with a sketch of knock do
and ask to catch him if they see him
around nakdu thinks of a plan and
gathers all of them a while later he
lies that he met the pervert and
attacked him giving him a scar on his
face he also changes the picture so it
would look different from the original
the women buy the story and start
looking for the man with a scar later
that day dongju's friend nyong yang
brings her a bunch of candies from the
palace dongju in turn gives them to
knock do because it is his birthday
meanwhile in the palace the queen is
mourning her newborn son who died at the
time of war today was the day he was
born hence the day brings back memories
for her moreover she is eating the same
candies as knock do in her son's memory
the noble man who couldn't have his way
with the little girl returns to the
widow's village this time his eyes are
on dongju according to the rule the
kasang will have to hand her over to the
man if he wishes to take her home but
even so when the head kissing is told
about his intentions she declines trying
to save dongju from a monster like him
the noble man makes a scene threatening
to sell the entire village as a result
dongju agrees to go with him in the
meantime nakdu is hiding inside a
cupboard to spy on the assassins who are
planning a way to kill their new target
a woman opens the cupboard
mid-conversation and catches nakdu
red-handed he quickly recovers by saying
that he came to steal a ring to make
more money the women get ready to kill
him but then he offers to join their
group they hear his case and decide to
give him a chance but only if he manages
to kill the man in the next two days in
the last scene dongju is being taken
away in a palanquin while knock doo is
on his way to kill the target to see
what happens next watch the second part
in series recap